Lo sé, a casi todos nos gusta viajar. Sin
embargo, os puedo asegurar, queridos amigos,
amigas, que hay sitios que es mejor
conocer a través de las tarjetas postales.
Lugares dónde fácilmente podréis perder
la cartera, el móvil o, incluso la vida.
Sin embargo, sabemos que entre
vosotros hay amantes del riesgo.
Personas que disfrutan cruzando
los límites de lo prohibido.
Por eso, en VisualPolitik, nos hemos tomado
la licencia de elaborar nuestro particular
ranking de las ciudades más peligrosas del
mundo. A la hora de hacerlo hemos dejado al
margen lugares que están bajo los efectos de
la guerra. Creemos que aportaría poco hablaros
de ciudades como Damasco, Kabul o la actual
Kiev. Para eso ya tenemos otro montón vídeos.
Este ránking lo hemos elaborado por regiones y
hemos tenido en cuenta diversos factores como
homicidios, atracos, corrupción, incidentes de
todo tipo o, incluso, expectativas. ¿Y sabéis qué?
El denominador común de estas ciudades es la
pobreza, la desigualdad, las drogas y la falta
de oportunidades para los más jóvenes. Un cóctel
explosivo que termina por desatar la violencia
en muchos lugares del mundo. En este vídeo
vamos a ver algunos de los más importantes.
Ninguno en Europa, y no porque no haya lugares
más o menos peligrosos. Podríamos hablaros de
Marsella, Nápoles o la albanesa Tropoja. Sin
embargo, lo de este ranking va a otro nivel.
Así que la pregunta es: ¿Cuáles son las
ciudades más peligrosas del mundo? ¿En
qué lugares tendrías que andar con mucho
ojo hasta para comprar una coca-cola?
Pues… Atentos.
Pero un momento, antes de arrancar con este
particular ranking, porque tenemos una noticia
muy pero que muy especial que daros. Querida
comunidad, la familia VisualPolitik crece en
todos los sentidos. En apenas unos días tendremos
con nosotros un nuevo canal: VisualEconomik.
Un nuevo canal que nace con el objetivo
de entender mejor cómo funciona el mundo
de la economía. ¿Habéis oído hablar de
la deuda perpetua? ¿Qué problemas tiene
el sistema eléctrico? ¿Se puede crear dinero sin
generar inflación? ¿Qué pasaría
si todos los bancos quebraran?
Pues ya podéis suscribiros y darle a la
campanita para estar al tanto de nuestro
primer vídeo. Os esperamos y esperamos
también vuestras impresiones. De momento,
la primera pregunta es para todos vosotros. Si
las camisetas hawaianas son de VisualPolitik
y los chalecos de Megaprojekts, ¿Cuál será
el look característico de este nuevo canal?
¿Alguna idea? Hagan sus apuestas. Os dejamos
por aquí el enlace y también en la descripción.
(DEL INDO A LOS MARES DEL SUR)
(Puesto número 3 es para Yangón.)
Myanmar, ese país que todo el
mundo conoce como Birmania,
es un auténtico polvorín. En 2005 Yangón dejó de
ser la capital pero sigue siendo con diferencia
la principal ciudad del país. Hace un año los
militares dieron un golpe de Estado, otro más,
con el que regresaron formalmente al poder.
Desde entonces las fuerzas de seguridad han
aplastado cualquier conato de protesta y la
moneda local perdió un tercio de su valor,
asentando un duro golpe a la ya de por
sí maltrecha economía de los birmanos.
Así que, si no eres víctima de un robo, corres
el riesgo de que una pelota de goma perdida se
cruce en tu camino. Eso sí, bajo ningún
concepto se te ocurra decir que te gustan
la redes sociales. Facebook está bloqueado y
el régimen militar sigue estrechando el cerco.
(Myanmar renueva planes para frenar el
uso de Internet con la prohibición de VPN)
¿Prohibir las VPN? Está claro que en VisualPolitik
no podemos estar más en contra de esto. Cómo dijo
William Wallace, “puede que nos quiten la
vida, pero jamás nos quitarán la libertasd”.
(Puesto número 2 es para Karachi.)
Con cerca de 20 millones de habitantes,
sobrevivir en la ciudad más poblada de
Pakistán tiene mérito. La tensión étnica
y sectaria se respira en plena calle.
Karachi se encuentra en la provincia de Sindh.
Pero muchos de sus habitantes no son sindhis sino
mojayires, musulmanes procedentes de la India.
A ellos se suman los pastunes, procedentes de
las zonas fronterizas con Afganistán. Algo que
ha llenado la ciudad de integristas islámicos.
Aún así el principal enemigo de todos
los karachíes sigue siendo la pobreza.
Son frecuentes los atracos violentos en
sus interminables atascos de tráfico;
atascos en ocasiones provocados por barricadas
colocadas por las propias bandas criminales.
La buena noticia es que las autoridades se
están moviendo para salir de este ranking.
(El Proyecto Karachi Ciudad Segura, dotado con
150 millones de euros, prevé instalar en la ciudad
alrededor de 10.000 cámaras de videovigilancia
con tecnología de reconocimiento facial.
También prevé reemplazar en los vehículos las
placas de matrícula tradicionales por placas de
identificación por radiofrecuencia capaces de ser
detectadas por estas cámaras. El problema es que
Karachi Ciudad Segura lleva ya 7 años de retraso
y acumula un sin fin de escándalos de corrupción.)
Y ojo, porque si conseguís escapar a
todo esto, vuestra salud aún correrá
peligro. Karachi es una de las ciudades
más contaminadas del mundo por el tráfico
rodado y la quema descontrolada de basura.
El sistema de alcantarillado es horrible,
no hay agua potable y abundan los mosquitos
transmisores de enfermedades. Por si esto fuera
poco, los servicios sanitarios son malos
y caros. Así que, si no eres Bin Laden,
tienes poco que hacer por estas tierras.
(Puesto número 1 para… Port Moresby)
La capital de Papúa Nueva Guinea es un lugar
tan pobre y peligroso que cuando en 2018 le tocó
al país ser anfitrión de la reunión anual de la
APEC, a la que acudieron entre otros Xi Jinping,
Trudeau o el vicepresidente Pence, tuvieron
que alquilar 3 cruceros para acoger a todas
las delegaciones y garantizar su seguridad.
En la ciudad la tasa de desempleo es superior
al 50%. Con una población de 250.000 habitantes,
es un lugar donde las tasas de homicidios son
excepcionalmente altas, gracias principalmente a
las pandillas raskol, que controlan grandes áreas.
Se recomienda a los visitantes
de Port Moresby que no salgan de
su alojamiento después de la puesta del
sol y que durante el día eviten caminar
por las calles en prácticamente toda la
ciudad. Los raskol son capaces de todo:
desde atracar bancos con ametralladoras M-16
hasta asaltar vehículos armados con machetes.
Pero esperad un momento, este no es el único
galardón que ha recibido Port Moresby. Fijaos.
(Port Moresby: ¿La ciudad más
peligrosa del mundo para ser mujer?)
Ni más ni menos que el 41% de los hombres
encuestados en Papúa Nueva Guinea admiten
haber violado a una mujer que no era su pareja.
Y teniendo en cuenta las agresiones dentro de
la pareja, un estudio de Human Rights
Watch eleva estas cifras hasta el 70%.
Y ahí no terminan todos los problemas.
Las cacerías de brujas, en las que las
mujeres son acusadas de hechicería, ocurren con
frecuencia y acaban en su tortura y asesinato.
Así podemos quitar el interrogante: Port Moresby
es el peor lugar del planeta para ser mujer.
(MEMORIAS DE ÁFRICA)
(Puesto número 3… Para Lagos)
Con más de 15 millones de habitantes,
esta es la segunda ciudad más poblada de
África y el centro económico de Nigeria.
Sin embargo, la inseguridad en Lagos es tan
alta que muchos niños faltan a las escuelas
por temor a ser secuestrados. Y
no, la policía no sirve de nada.
Son pocos, mal formados y peor pagados. Esto
deja el camino despejado a los matones locales,
los llamados Area Boys, pandillas
de jóvenes que roban en las casas
y asaltan vehículos. Y luego está
el peligro que suponen las okada.
(Las okada son mototaxis que brindan una
opción económica y rápida para escapar de
los constantes atascos. El problema es que su
principal método para conseguirlo consiste en no
respetar las normas de circulación más básicas,
como avanzar en dirección prohibida. Así que
coger una okada es una de las mejores opciones
para acabar el día en algún hospital de Lagos.)
Además, las autoridades de Lagos se están
planteando prohibir estos mototaxis, de los
que se estima que hay 1 millón recorriendo
sus calles, por la colaboración que algunos
de sus pilotos mantienen con los Area Boys
correspondientes. Lo cierto, sin embargo,
es que prohibir las okada agravaría la pobreza
en Lagos ya que Nigeria es el país del mundo con
mayor población joven y la mitad se encuentran
sin trabajo y/o en condiciones muy precarias.
(Puesto 2 para Kinshasa)
La capital de la República Democrática del
Congo, una vez tan hermosa hasta el punto
de ser conocida como “Kin la belle”,
ha cambiado tanto que sus habitantes
hoy día la llaman “Kin la poubelle”, que
viene a querer decir “Kin el basurero”.
Y por si la basura acumulada y las
alcantarillas malolientes no fueran
suficientemente desagradables, la ciudad
congoleña está traumatizada por los Kulunas,
un grupo de jóvenes armados con
machetes que roban y matan a diestro
y siniestro . Una amenaza agravada en el
último año por los zombis de Kinshasa.
(Las calles de Kinshasa han sido invadidas
por una nueva droga barata con efectos muy
potentes. Hablamos del Bombé, una sustancia
elaborada a partir de los depósitos de los
catalizadores de los automóviles. Se
extrae de los coches viejos abandonados
en los desguaces y luego se procesa como
una droga. Después de tomar el bombé,
los kuluna primero se ponen eufóricos, momento
en el que cometen toda clase de delitos. Pero
luego estos jóvenes comienzan a moverse cada vez
más lentamente hasta parecer auténticos zombis.)
Desde 2020 se ha producido un nuevo
aumento de la actividad kuluna en Kinshasa,
lo que ha dado lugar a un aumento de los
delitos graves, incluidos los robos a mano
armada y las agresiones violentas. Por
supuesto, una vez más la pobreza es la
causa de tanto crimen. Una gran parte
de los 15 millones de personas que se
estima que viven en Kinshasa no tiene trabajo
fijo ni ingresos regulares de ningún tipo.
(Puesto 1 para Ciudad del Cabo)
Sudáfrica redujo sus niveles de violencia
desde que adoptó la democracia en 1994. Pero
las cosas cambiaron en la última década.
El crimen violento se ha disparado por
una mezcla peligrosa de pobreza, armas y
una policía que deja bastante que desear.
Puede que te sorprenda pero esto ha ocurrido
particularmente en una ciudad tan turística
y conocida como Ciudad del Cabo, un lugar
dónde los homicidios se han disparado un 60%.
Los territorios dominados por
las pandillas son los Cape Flats,
los barrios marginales para la población
negra en tiempos del apartheid.
Allí mandan bandas como The Americans,
The Numbers Gang o los Laughing Boys.
Y así hasta las aproximadamente
130 pandillas a las que se estima
que pertenecen alrededor de
100.000 personas en los Flats.
En estos barrios son frecuentes las
batallas por el territorio entre bandas,
lo que provoca olas de violencia que aterrorizan a
Ciudad del Cabo. ¿Y de donde salen todas las armas
que circulan por los Flats? Pues atentos,
porque salen del sitio más insospechado.
(Ex policía condenado a 18 años por robar
y revender armas a mafiosos del Cabo)
En total, los investigadores relacionaron
más de mil asesinatos y unos 1.500 intentos
de asesinato solo con estas armas. Y lo
peor es que no es un caso aislado. Los
policías corruptos manipulan los expedientes
judiciales de los pandilleros arrestados.
La tasa de condena por asesinato en los
Flats apenas alcanza el 2%. Por tanto,
ante tal impunidad, no debe extrañarnos que
las bandas callejeras sigan dominando zonas
que ahora reciben nombres tan significativos
como Cowboy Town, Taliban Area y la Jungla.
Sí, puedes visitar Ciudad del Cabo y pasártelo
pipa. Pero más allá de los hoteles de lujo y
E.las zonas caras, esta es la otra realidad
que se está imponiendo en la ciudad.
(LA TIERRA SIN OPORTUNIDADES)
(Puesto 3 para San Pedro Sula)
Con todo, América Latina sigue siendo
la región más violenta del mundo. Los
conflictos entre pandillas,
la corrupción y la debilidad
institucional contribuyen a los altos
niveles de violencia en toda la región.
Durante años San Pedro Sula lució el indeseable
título de ser la ciudad con más asesinatos del
mundo. Este lugar se convirtió en punto obligado
de paso del 80% de la cocaína que circulaba desde
Colombia con destino a Estados Unidos. Estamos
hablando de territorio controlado por las maras.
(La mara salvatrucha instaló cámaras
en barrios de San Pedro Sula para
controlar a la población y a la policía.)
La falta de oportunidades sigue propiciando
que los jóvenes, algunos incluso de apenas
12 años, sean reclutados por estas Maras.
Desde hace años el país ha intentado limpiar
de corrupción a sus fuerzas de seguridad y
ha conseguido reducir los niveles de violencia.
Pero aún no se puede bajar la guardia en lugares
como San Pedro Sula, donde la extorsión y los
secuestros siguen estando a la orden del día.
(Puesto número 2 para St. Louis)
Esta es otra ciudad que sorprende en este ranking
y a la cual en VisualPolitik ya le
hemos dedicado un vídeo completo.
De mayoría afroamericana, St. Louis, una ciudad
de 300.000 habitantes en el estado de Missouri,
sufre la tasa de violencia más elevada
de todo Estados Unidos. En ella los
tiroteos son frecuentes y suelen darse en los
suburbios ubicados en el norte de la ciudad.
Las pandillas no son especialmente un problema en
St. Louis, pero sí lo son el tráfico de drogas y
la violencia armada. En 2020 esta ciudad batió su
macabro récord: 262 asesinatos en tan solo un año.
De todos los homicidios,
apenas se resuelve un tercio por la falta
de efectivos de las fuerzas policiales
(Puesto número 1 para Caracas)
La capital de Venezuela atraviesa una
ola de violencia sin precedentes y sus
5 millones de habitantes sufren
un deterioro constante de los
servicios públicos debido a la mala
administración del régimen chavista.
Menos de una quinta parte de los venezolanos
se sienten seguros caminando por la calle
durante la noche y la policía tiene que
hacer inspecciones rutinarias para buscar
armas hasta en los autobuses urbanos
que circulan en los barrios más pobres.
Lugares como la Cota 905 han sido escenario de
intensos tiroteos entre las bandas criminales y
las fuerzas policiales que han paralizado la
vida cotidiana. En VisualPolitik ya sabemos
cómo se las gasta la dictadura de Nicolás
Maduro. Los mafiosos de Caracas también.
N5 (Fuerzas de seguridad venezolanas
abatieron a “El Koki”, presunto
líder de una banda que aterrorizó Caracas)
La mala gestión y la hiperinflación ha empobrecido
a la sociedad y ha ampliado la brecha entre
quienes tienen acceso a dólares y los que no. En
esta tesitura, muchos no tienen más alternativa
que recurrir al crimen así que, como podéis
imaginar, los billetes verdes son muy codiciados
en Caracas. Cuidado entonces con vuestra cartera.
Pero, se lo que muchos estáis pensando. ¿Ya
está todo? ¿Es que no pensáis hablar de México?
4 (DUELO MEXICANO)
Lo siento mucho por todos los que
nos veís desde este fantástico país,
pero si hablamos de ciudades violentas
México reclama su propia sección.
Año tras año sus ciudades lideran los
rankings mundiales de homicidios. Y es que,
el país tiene la desgracia de estar
directamente entre los campos de coca
de Sudamérica y Estados Unidos, el mayor
mercado de narcóticos del mundo. Así que…
(Puesto número 3 para Ciudad Juárez)
La ciudad fronteriza de Ciudad Juárez se convirtió
durante años en el campo de batalla más sangriento
de la guerra contra el narco lanzada por el
Gobierno mexicano. Una ciudad de 1,5 millones
de habitantes llegó a sufrir más de 300 asesinatos
al mes. La extorsión, el secuestro y el robo de
vehículos se volvieron endémicos. Esto le hizo ser
reconocida como la ciudad más peligrosa del mundo.
La lucha por el territorio debilitó
y fragmentó los cárteles más grandes
que operaban por la zona, como el
antaño todopoderoso Cártel de Juárez.
Pero ahora se está recrudeciendo la violencia.
Los homicidios están volviendo a crecer debido
a que los cárteles locales más pequeños
están actualmente luchando entre sí por
su participación en el negocio
de la metanfetamina cristalina.
(Puesto número 2 para Acapulco)
Ojo, recordad que este ranking no
solo depende del número de homicidios.
Amigos, amigas, en los años 90 las
playas de Acapulco se pusieron de
moda y alcanzaron fama mundial. Pero
en 2007 comenzaron los problemas.
La violencia estalló después de que el
cártel dominante se dividiera. El trono
vacante fue rápidamente ocupado
por grupos locales más pequeños.
Comenzó entonces una brutal lucha por
el territorio. Aquello acabó con el
prestigio de Acapulco como un destino
idílico de vacaciones. Pero un momento,
porque ahora las autoridades tienen un
plan infalible para mejorar su reputación.
(No escriban sobre violencia
por el bien del turismo,
dice la alcaldesa de Acapulco a los periodistas)
Claro que sí, alcaldesa. ¡Silenciar los
crímenes es la mejor forma de acabar con
los secuestros y las extorsiones!
Y ver a los soldados patrullando
por las playas seguro que deja a los
turistas muchísimo más tranquilos. El
gran problema es que la impunidad es
prácticamente total en esta ciudad.
Y a falta de un cártel dominante, hay unas cuantas
organizaciones criminales dedicadas al tráfico de
heroína, producida a partir de amapolas cultivadas
a lo largo del estado de Guerrero y distribuida
desde allí a Estados Unidos. Y ya sabéis que
donde abunda la droga, abundan los problemas.
(Puesto 1 para Tijuana)
Tijuana es quizás la ciudad más peligrosa
del mundo. La lucha contra el narcotráfico
ha tenido efectos contraproducentes
para la ciudad fronteriza de la Baja
California. La captura de capos ha dejado a
los cárteles fragmentados y luchando entre sí.
Y Tijuana está siendo uno de sus principales
campos de batalla. La tasa de homicidios
prácticamente se ha triplicado en los
últimos 5 años y es 20 veces más alta
que el promedio mundial. Matan a tantas
personas que no dan abasto en Tijuana.
Todos conocemos seguro a
una de sus últimas víctimas:
la periodista Lourdes Maldonado que había pedido
ayuda y protección al mismísimo presidente AMLO.
Nosotros sólo podemos mandar mucho ánimo a todos
los que nos veis desde todas estas ciudades.
Pero ahora la pregunta es para ti:
¿Echáis en falta alguna ciudad en este
particular top 3 por regiones? Dejadnos
vuestros comentarios y si este vídeo os
ha resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
a like y suscribiros a VisualPolitik si
áún no lo habéis hecho. Y ahora también,
no lo olvidéis, a nuestro nuevo
canal hermano, VisualEconomik
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.